taz le décryptage politique c'est tous
les jours sur public sénat
enfin
non
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat dans un instant vous allez pouvoir
suivre l'ouverture de la session
ordinaire par le président du sénat
gérard larcher
puis la suite de l'examen du projet de
loi dit grenelle 2 la discussion reprend
à l'article 34 cet article précise les
critères de définition des zones de
développement de l'éolien
pour le gouvernement il s'agit de
limiter l'implantation d'éoliennes dans
les zones protégées
alors que pour l'opposition il ya trop
de freins juridiques au développement de
l'éolien en france
en pleine discussion du titre iii sur la
promotion des énergies renouvelables
voilà pour les enjeux de la séance de
cet après-midi bonne après midi à tous
sur public sénat l'ordre du jour appelle
la suite de la discussion du projet de
loi portant engagement national pour
l'environnement
nous sommes parvenus à l'article 34-1
monsieur raoul merci nous mêmes le
présidentde je profite de la possibilité
de l'article du règlement qui nous
permet d'intervenir avant de discuter la
suite de l'article 34
nous préparons à poursuivre cette
semaine encore nos débats sur le projet
de loi portant engagement national pour
l'environnement mais nous souhaitons
dénoncer un jeu de dupes qui jouer à la
fois par le gouvernement et la majorité
alors nous fixons dans ce projet de loi
dit grenelle 2 et modalités
d'application des grands principes
adoptés lors du grenelle 1
nous constatons avec amertume le manque
d'engagement en particulier sur le plan
financier qui se traduit par la
présentation d'un projet de loi de
finances pour 2010 totalement dénué de
moyens financiers concernant ce qui nous
préoccupe dans ce projet de loi nous
avions soutenu avant l'été mais nous
avions été volontariste pour deux pour
soutenir le grenelle 1 qui nous invitait
à une véritable évolution de nos
pratiques au quotidien
néanmoins nous vous avions a alors
averti que nous serions vigie
ce que le grenelle 2 ne revienne pas sur
ses engagements et notre vote et qui
valait un engagement de notre part comme
de la vôtre madame la ministre et
messieurs les membres de la majorité
par conséquent nous sommes engagés de
manière active et constructive dans la
discussion du projet de grenelle 2 et
nos amendements ont certes quelquefois
été pris en considération mais à quoi
bon poursuivre nos efforts quand nous
constatons pertinemment que les moyens
ne suivant pas le budget pour 2010
présenté la semaine dernière par le
gouvernement et que vous avez tous
épluché pendant le week-end affiche une
dette publique incontrôlable et laisse
se creuser un déficit de près de 140
milliards d'euros devenu abyssal et qui
prive de fait l'état de ses moyens
d'action la taxe carbone que vous
proposez de mettre en oeuvre telle
qu'elle est prévue est à l'heure pour
nos concitoyens inefficace
économiquement et véritable gruyère
fiscale elle ne permettra pas
d'atteindre l'objectif de réduction des
gaz à effet de serre et le en
particulier d'atteindre le fameux
facteur 4 que notre pays s'est fixé
d'ailleurs la façon de la de
redistribuer cette fameuse contribution
climat énergie est ce qu'elle va être
assortie aussi d'un bulletin d'adhésion
à l'ump comme avait été la réduction de
la tva à 5,5
je me pose des questions sur
l'utilisation des fichiers
pire encore les collectivités
territoriales sur lesquels repose une
grande partie des obligations des
investissements prévus par le grenelle
de l'environnement seront totalement
asphyxiée financièrement par l'évolution
la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle que propose le
gouvernement est en tous les cas je peux
vous dire que nos collectivités à
l'heure actuelle n'ont aucune visibilité
sur le budget 2010 de me lancer suivant
concernés par la taxe carbone elles
mêmes leurs charges de fonctionnement
chauffage dans les écoles transports
publics vont donc considérablement être
augmentée et ceci sans ressources
supplémentaires
or les efforts des collectivités
territoriales dans le développement des
énergies
renouvelables et pour la diminution des
fameux g us ne sont plus à démontrer
alors que met en oeuvre d'un porte
d'importants politiques territoriales de
développement durable agenda 21 plan
énergie climat et collectivités verront
leurs ressources diminuer ce que j'ai pu
voir des projets en tous les cas de
dotations aux collectivités dans le
projet de loi de finances c'est que les
dotations ce raid dans la cadre de la
dgf augmenté de 0 6% c'est-à-dire la
moitié de l'inflation constatée ce qui
équivaut en euros évidemment constant
une diminution de leurs moyens d'action
comment dans ce cas pourrait-elle
développer les transports publics ou la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
publics
plus grave encore le gouvernement se
défausse sur les collectivités
territoriales étant un véritable piège
région en leur permettant dans le projet
de loi de finances pour 2010 d'augmenter
leur part de tei ppp pour financer
obligatoirement les projets du grenelle
de l'environnement
je parle de leur participation en ligne
à grande vitesse infrastructures
fluviales qui relève pourtant
normalement de la compétence de l'état
dans le cadre de l'aménagement des
territoires
à l'heure où le gouvernement compte
instaurer une taxe carbone et la
compenser il impose donc aux régions
d'augmenter lé té i pp qui viendra en
deux fait peser encore plus sur les
ménages
cette opération alors à la proche des
élections régionales ne peut durer plus
longtemps
le budget dont nous débattons dont nous
débattrons prochainement et j'entame
d'ailleurs le débat entraîne un
basculement important de la fiscalité
sur les ménages
en octroyant des cadeaux à justifier et
en maintenant le bouclier fiscal pour
les revenus les plus élevés vous dites
vouloir mettre l'outil fiscal au service
de l'environnement
je vous ai bien entendu madame vous vous
trompez votre projet de loi de finances
ne permettra pas notre pays de s'engager
pleinement dans la mutation écologique
je comprends que bercy vous limite où
vous taille des ailes pour vous empêcher
de vous envoler
mais quand même c'est bien transfert sur
les collectivités qui va s'opérer en
fonction des compétences que nous mêmes
ici dans le cas de grenelle 1
et deux nous sommes en train de mettre à
la charge des collectivités
ce budget également à l'heure pour le
parlementaire que nous sommes en effet
si rien n'est prévu dans ce projet de
loi de finances on nous annonce les
jeunes loi de finances rectificatif pour
mettre en place le grand emprunt dont
les modalités sont pour le moment flou
est soumis aux pressions les plus
diverses
dans ces conditions mais chers collègues
le groupe socialiste peut continuer à
importer les yeux fermés son soutien aux
différents articles de ce projet de loi
oui mais monsieur monsieur raoul nous
prenons acte de votre déclaration
on vous a laissé vous exprimer largement
car comme vous le savez le temps de
parole est une est limitée à 5 minutes
alors à l'article à l'article n'aura
l'article 34 il ya une demande de parole
de monsieur roland courteau lui donne la
parole
merci mme la présidente oui je
souhaitais intervenir sur cet article 34
qui traite du développement maîtrisé de
l'énergie éolienne est bien évidemment
je suis très favorable au développement
de l'éolien
je suis d'autant plus que ce
développement est encadrée et maîtrisé
dès lors on pourrait me dire que cet
article 34 est de nature à nous
satisfaire
eh bien ce n'est pas tout à fait le cas
je m'interroge en effet sur certaines
dispositions comme par exemple
l'inscription des éoliennes dans la
procédure dite simplifiée d'autorisation
des installations classées ou encore
l'intégration de critères
supplémentaires dans la définition d un
d eux
zte qui ne concerneront plus l'éolien en
mer mais seulement l'éolien terrestre
en fait je crains que l'objectif de
maîtrise poursuivi nous soit en réalité
qu'un verrou supplémentaire imposée au
développement de l'éolien terrestre
puisque l'éolien offshore semble
bénéficier d'un certain nombre de
ges si j'ai bien compris pour le
gouvernement le développement maîtrisé
de l'éolien passe par une sorte de
verrouillage des l'éolien terrestre et
l'ouverture maximum de l'éolien en mer
or en matière de développement maîtrisé
et équilibrée une autre réponse peut
être apportée sans qu'il soit nécessaire
de durcir la législation actuelle mais
par une meilleure planification des
projets éoliens dans le cadre justement
des schémas régionaux
il n'est parfois répondu qu'il est
nécessaire de rajouter certaines
contraintes pour me prendre en compte
certaines préoccupations telles l'impact
sonore les risques d'accident les
perturbations électromagnétiques etc
faut-il alors rappelé que la législation
existante couvrent chacun de ses
inconvénients
le code de l'urbanisme le code de la
santé publique
le code de l'environnement le code des
postes et télécommunications et même le
code de l'aviation civile couvrent
chacun des problèmes susceptibles
d'apparaître
j'avoue ne pas comprendre un certain
durcissement de la réglementation alors
que l'afsset l'afsset considère que la
législation actuelle et des plus
protectrices que penser par exemple de
l'intégration des critères
supplémentaires dans la définition des
zones de développement de l'éolien
ces zones sont d'ores et déjà défini sur
la base de trois critères potentiel
éolien de la zone possibilités de
raccordement au réseau électrique et
protection des paysages des monuments
historiques et sites remarquables et
protégés
pourquoi ajouter des critères
supplémentaires faute il l'a aussi
rappelé une instruction ministérielle de
juin 2006 qui précisait que je cite dans
la mesure où la proposition de scinder
ne fait pas mention d'implantation
précise pour la réalisation de futurs
parcs éoliens il ne saurait être
question de conduire à une analyse aussi
détaillé que celle qui est menée lors de
l'instruction du permis de construire
fin de citation c'est clair
de fait actuellement l'analyse
exhaustive et précise des conséquences
du développement d'un parc éolien est
effectuée lors de l'étude d'impact et de
l' enquête publique prévue dans le cadre
du permis de construire
dois-je préciser enfin que notre
législation est déjà l'une des plus
contraignantes d'europe
et croyez moi elle est scrupuleusement
appliqué si j'en juge par le nombre de
rejet de projet décidé par
l'administration alors où veut en venir
je crois avoir compris que le
gouvernement veut considérablement
limiter le développement de l'éolien
terrestre pour mieux ouvrir l'éolien en
mer à de gigantesques parcs éoliens ce
qui explique les assouplissement de la
législation que vous accordez à l'off
shore suppression du plafond de 12
mégawatts
exclusion du dispositif d aide d e 10
passes de certaines dispositions
d'urbanisme
ces assouplissements vont même très loin
puisqu'il est proposé que les garanties
financières pour la remise en état des
sites ne sont pas constitués dès le
début de la construction comme c'est le
cas actuellement mais seulement au cours
de la construction
prenons la reine chers collègues nous
risquons avoir de mauvaises surprises
sur nos paysages marins avec des
constructions commencé et jamais terminé
mais au delà du fait que des pans
entiers de nos territoires de
l'arrière-pays seront pénalisés il reste
à savoir si globalement amusant
l'essentiel l'offshore et en
verrouillant les éoliennes terrestres
vous nous parviendrons à atteindre les
objectifs fixés à l'horizon 2020 je
conclu madame la présidente
enfin et si globalement je ne suis pas
défavorable à l'éolien offshore
j'aurais préféré que l'on agisse avec
plus de mesure car il ya aussi en mer
des paysages à préserver des sites
remarquables et protégés ainsi que des
zones de pêche dont il faut tenir le
plus grand compte
une position plus équilibrée entre
l'éolien terrestre et l'éolien en mer
nous paraît donc plus souhaitable merci
à chaque collègue
nous allons donc entamer l'étude et des
amendements en commençant par le numéro
5 138
vous présentez monsieur courteau avec
votre collègue bourquin oui même la
présidente des zones de développement de
l'éolien sont actuellement défini sur le
fondement n'est pas critères que je
viens de citer
je n'y reviens pas ces critères doivent
être nécessairement apprécié au niveau
macroscopique dans la mesure où
l'emplacement exact des projets n'est
pas connu lors de leur adoption
la z demeure ainsi un instrument de
planification électrique ayant pour seul
objet l'obtention de certificats
d'obligation d'achat pour les
installations implantées dans la zone
la création d'une telle zone ne préjuge
donc à rien de l'autorisation ultérieure
de construire les projets éventuels
il n'est par conséquent pas possible
d'évaluer dans le cadre de la zte
l'ensemble des critères énumérés à
l'article 34
comme le précise du reste la circulaire
relative à l'instruction des ide et
adressée au préfet le 19 juin 2006 et
que je viens de citer la protection des
intérêts nouvellement mentionnées telles
que la sécurité publique la biodiversité
et le patrimoine archéologique et
vérifier dans le cadre de diverses
études en particulier de l'étude
d'impact versés au dossier de permis de
construire est soumise à enquête
publique
les nouveaux critères énumérés dans le
troisième en dû premièrement du
paragraphe grands thèmes de cette
afrique ne sont donc pas appropriée eu
égard à l'objet de la zte raison pour
laquelle il est proposé de revenir au
texte actuel
merci quel est l'avis de la commission
le président chers collègues j'ai
l'impression que le ce n'est qu'une
impression qu il y a une méconnaissance
de la pratique actuelle pour la
définition des dde pour la définition
d'une aide de à vrai dire c'est un
promoteur qui vient voir les maires et
présidents de communautés de communes
pour dire écoute
ici il me semble qu'il ya du vent et c
est ce qu on pourrait pas monter un
dossier de z des biens et dans le
montage de ce projet de zte déjà alors
que ce n'est pas inscrit dans la loi
comme vous le soulignez les autorités
administratives prennent en compte la
présence de chiroptères 2000 en rouge
enfin bref de critères écologiques et
finalement la loi tel qu'il est rédigé
actuellement sortie de la commission
d'ailleurs je dois dire parce que ce que
proposait le gouvernement était encore
plus complet nous avons finalement
rajouter la sécurité publique je dois
dire que d'ailleurs et sécurité publique
aussi été examiné par les autorités
administratives et singulièrement par
les militaires mais l'armée de l'air
l'armée de l'air qui veillait à ce que
les éoliennes ne se trouve pas sur les
zones d'atterrissage et de décollage des
bases aériennes peu nombreuses qui
restent en france comme si je dis peu
nombreuses c'est parce que comme on en a
fermé un certain nombre il est important
que celles qui subsistent et et la
possibilité et ben de poursuivre leurs
activités c'est pourquoi la commission à
supprime un certain nombre de choses de
propositions du gouvernement et a
rajouté et a maintenu quand même la
sécurité publique
voilà donc par conséquent en revenir au
texte initial et au texte actuel
effectivement me paraît assez réducteur
dans le mesure où finalement la loi
vient toujours postérieurement aux
pratiques des choses est pratiquement
aujourd'hui tout ce qui est énumérée
dans ce qui est proposé est par la tête
par le texte de la commission tient
compte de ce qui se fait déjà
aussi la commission émet un avis
défavorable si l'amendement n'est pas
retiré l'avis de du gouvernement madame
la ministre
merci madame la présidente effectivement
on les entend que je pense qu'on a
atteint un bon compromis un bon
équilibre avec la commission on ne peut
pas retirer les questions de sécurité
parce que il ya des perturbations
observées sur les radars qui ne touche
pas seulement d'ailleurs les
installations militaires mais aussi les
installations de l'aviation civile ou de
la ou de la météo
et s'agissant de la biodiversité on
avait mené des études avec la
lp/o qui montre bien qu'il faut quand
même intégré ces problématiques de
biodiversité sur diverses espèces y
compris les espèces migratrices c'est
pourquoi on a aussi un avis défavorable
sur cet amendement s'il y avait une
explication de vote
oui monsieur courteau bon je suis pas du
tout d'accord les explications de
monsieur le rapporteur
j'ai l'impression que vous aussi
peut-être vous seriez vous auriez
intérêt à regarder et à vérifier ce que
vous aimez de m'affirmer
moi je persiste à dire que la
législation actuelle est suffisante dans
le cadre de la procédure et tout le
reste
en fait n'est destiné qu'à verrouiller
davantage l'éolien terrestre comme je le
disais tout à l'heure à l'internationa
tic d'ailleurs personne ni le rapporteur
ni madame la ministre de n'être
intervenu là dessus pour pour rebondir
maintenez-vous votre abonnement monsieur
coup bien alors je vais faire voter en
rappelant l'avis défavorable et de la
commission et du gouvernement
ceux qui sont favorables à l'adoption de
cet amendement voudront me a levé la
main et ceux qui sont contre
il n'est pas adoptée suis saisi de deux
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
édition commune à un seul puisque
l'auteur de l'amendement n'est pas là
monsieur business et le l'amendement
numéro 583 merci madame la présidente
madame la présidente monsieur madame le
ministre mes chers collègues je suis
désolé que mon collègue roland du luart
ne soit pas là pour défendre un
amendement identique mais il leur était
sans doute beaucoup mieux fait par lui
je voudrais
rappelé je voudrais rappeler que les
comptes de visibilité ont pour objet de
garantir la protection des sites et des
paysages paysage de qualité un site du
patrimoine bâti en créant une zone dont
sont exclus les éoliennes
cet amendement ajoute en conséquence le
critère de visibilité à ceux relatifs à
la création des zones de développement
de l'éolien
il reprend de la sorte les instructions
du gouvernement aux préfets de région et
de département c'était la circulaire qui
avait fait passer madame albanel
le 15 septembre 2008 j'ajoute pour avoir
eu un aparté tout d'heure avec mon
collègue jean françois legrand qui
l'aurait souhaité également souligné
qu'une étude d'impact global puisse être
menée lorsque plusieurs projets sont
juxtaposés ça les fait d'ailleurs
l'objet
je dirais d'une discussion en commission
alors madame la ministre je voudrais
tout simplement vous rappeler que je ne
suis pas du tout un anti éoliens
primaire je crois que ça ne va pas
heurter notre notre rapporteur
je suis pareil je suis effectivement
trop respectueux des engagements que
nous avons pris au travers des
directives européennes en matière
d'énergies renouvelables
mais vous conviendrez qu'on ne peut pas
mettre des éoliennes n'importe où ni
n'importe comment et que si chacun
d'entre nous peut je dirais constaté que
des éoliennes dans un paysage qui est
celui des zones céréalières que je
qualifierais comme des paysages un peu
plutôt neutre autant autant en zone
bocagères les éoliennes sont à mon avis
quelque peu incongru et donc il faut
faire quand même très très attention
attention madame la ministre à ne pas
dépasser les limites de l'acceptation
sociétale de nos concitoyens au nom d'un
engagement au niveau du grenelle au
risque tout simplement de provoquer un
profond rejet de nos concitoyens vous
rappeler que la france étant une
destination touristique majeure des
étrangers ce qui n'est pas spécialement
compatible avec la présence d'éoliennes
en certains secteurs c'est la raison
pour laquelle tant roland du luart comme
moi même nous souhaiterions voir adopter
cet amendement
malgré l'avis du rapporteur qui jusqu'à
maintenant étaient
pas tout à fait celui là merci quel est
l'avis de la commission monsieur
rapporteur oui alors nous regrettons
tous ça me suffisait que notre éminent
collègue ne soit pas là pour défendre
son amendement qui est quasiment
identique aux autres mais pas identique
sinon ils ne sont qu'en discussion
commune
ceci étant dit je vous dirais que ce que
l'on vient d'examiner à l'instant avec
l'amendement de notre collègue
le texte prévoit que les monuments
historiques sont déjà largement prise en
compte par part finalement ce qui est
proposé par le texte de loi et préserver
les paysages les monuments historiques
et les sites remarquables et protégés
là ce que dit le texte de loi qui vous
est proposé et donc il nous semble à la
commission que ce que vous proposez
n'est jamais qu'une modalité technique
de l'application de ce qui est écrit
dans le texte de loi qui qui vous est
proposée par la commission et par
conséquent certes je serais d'accord
avec l'auteur de cet amendement pour
dire que les zones céréalières sont
certainement moins géorgiques que les
zones de pâturage
mais pour autant tout est bien bien
encadré il y a même l'administration
actuellement qui va bien au delà de la
loi actuelle prend en compte au delà des
oiseaux migrateurs
la sécurité publique avec la météo etc
la sécurité civile l'aviation civile et
l'aviation militaire les prend en compte
également le phénomène
un nouveau concept si le concept
d'encerclement vous auriez pu proposer
également effectivement ce ce concept
dans votre amendement
donc je veux dire que l'administration
va déjà d'ores et déjà comme l'habitude
de le faire d'ailleurs bien au delà du
texte de loi et par conséquent pour ce
qui nous concerne la commission nous
estimons que votre amendement s'il n'est
complètement satisfait et très largement
satisfaits aussi ai-je l'honneur de vous
demander de retirer votre amendement
chaque élection nous serions obligés d'y
être défavorable
merci la vie du gouvernement madame la
ministre merci mr le président oui enfin
effectivement je comprends votre
inquiétude quand on voit certains
projets notamment près du mont saint
michel mais qui ne sont que des projets
qui ne sont pas autorisés et qui nous le
serons certainement pas parce que ce
sont des projets complètement
complètement aberrant c'est vrai qu'on a
déjà la circulaire ministérielle qui
prévoit bien qu'on prenne en compte la
visibilité et les monuments historiques
elle ne va pas jusqu'à l'interdiction
totale parce que si on allait sur
l'interdiction totale pour les monuments
historiques pour le littoral sachant que
les 40000 monument historique en france
dans un cercle de covisibilité de 10 km
on pourrait plus en fait effectivement
implanter deux implantés d'éoliennes
donc ça reviendrait concrètement à
interdire l'implantation d'éoliennes on
pense qu'avec le schéma régional air
énergie climat le schéma de
développement des énergies renouvelables
et les les commissions qu'on a mis en
place on a maintenant quelque chose de
suffisamment cadrée pour avoir un
développement équilibré et tenir compte
des monuments historiques mais je veux
vraiment vous rassurer en tout cas les
exemples que qui nous sont cités parfois
comme mauvais exemple ce ne sont que des
projets qui ne sont pas autorisés merci
monsieur bizet après les filles assurent
qu'ils ont été donnés maintenez vous
votre amendement dans la présente
d'emblée mise mais chers collègues
malgré je dirais les assurances que
vient de me donner madame la ministre
très honnêtement je trouve que c'est
insuffisant il y a quand même dans
certains territoires de notre
le pays des endroits remarquables qui
mérite qu'on soit plus coercitif encore
et franchement je je sais quels sont les
risques que je prends mais je ne
retirerai pas mon amendement alors je
vais faire procéder au vote sur cet
amendement
ceux qui sont favorables à l'adoption de
l'amendement présenté je me suis visé
voudront bien l'exprimer en levant la
main ceux qui sont contre
il n'est pas adopté l'amendement 338
n'est pas défendu ils tombent
l'amendement numéro 541 que des formes
monsieur courteau non monsieur raoul
je vais essayer d'être court d'être
court cette fois là madame la présidente
et de respecter les temps actuellement
la procédure préalable à la mise en
service des éoliennes repose sur la
procédure du permis de construire
la délivrance de ce permis de construire
est précédée par une étude d'impact et
d'une enquête publique pour les
éoliennes de plus de 50 mètres de
hauteur
quant à la zone de développement de
l'éolien les fameux des fameuses zte
comme nous venons de le souligner elle
ne constitue en fait qu'un instrument de
planification électrique et elle ne
préjuge en rien de l'autorisation
ultérieure de construire les projets
éventuels
c'est à ce seul stade qu'il est possible
et pertinents d'appréhender clairement
les enjeux de protection
environnementaux sanitaires
technologique sécurité publique n'aura
on en rajoute encore pour cette raison
même nous souhaitons supprimer le
troisièmement du grand teint de cet
article qui prévoit que la décision du
préfet n'interviendra qu'après avis la
commission départementale compétente en
matière d'environnement et de risque
sanitaire
or vous savez le travail que nous avons
réalisé dans le cadre du titre 1
concernant les fameuses commissions
régionales et donc c'est pas la
commission départementale compétente en
matière d'environnement de risques
sanitaires et technologiques qui sera en
mesure de donner un avis sur les risques
représenterait l'exploitation d'un parc
éolien notamment en termes d'impact
éventuellement on pourrait accepter que
vous corrigiez que vous disiez la
commission régionale mais en tous les
cas dans l'état du texte
nous souhaitons supprimer cette
commission dont l'avis de cette
commission des parcs
merci monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de
la commission
et pardonnez moi madame la présidente
d'être un peu long dans les explications
de
dur à porter son avis de la commission
mais je ne peux que répéter ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure parce que cet
amendement tend à nous faire penser que
au niveau de l'étude de la zdf cette
commission une de plus départementale ne
peut pas se prononcer d'une façon
pertinente au stade de l'étude
à vrai dire quand on veut bien regarder
enfin la petite expérience que j'en ai
puisque finalement en haute marne
nous avons une puissance sinon installé
au moins déjà autorisés qui me donne une
certaine expérience puisque dans mon
canton on va voir la ferme la plus
importante de france
quarante trois éoliennes comment ça se
passe c'est que le promoteur présente à
la commission un projet complet projet
de zte et dans ce projet il y à l'impact
paysager il y à l'emplacement des
éoliennes leur puissance
il y as tout absolument tout est par
conséquent je je considère que tel que
ça se passe actuellement est la
procédure qui est utilisé actuellement
où la lp o interviewer bref toutes les
associations de protection de la nature
interviennent je pense que avec
l'encadrement que nous mettons dans
cette loi là dans le grenelle 2 la
procédure me paraît tout à fait
pertinente et on fait que rejoindre
d'ailleurs la pratique des choses et la
loi précise un certain nombre de
possibilités pour ces commissions
départementales aussi nommé au budget
que défavorable à cet amendement s'il
venait retirer 6 merci madame la
ministre
même avis monsieur raoul vous maintenez
votre maman bien alors je vais faire
voter sur cet amendement
ceux qui sont favorables à son adoption
voudront bien exprimée en levant la main
ceux qui sont contre
il n'est pas adopté deux amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 497 présentée par
monsieur tropea news il n'est pas il
n'est pas défendu l'amendement numéro
535 monsieur courteau oui madame la
présidente la législation actuelle
oblige les exploitants d'éoliennes à
constituer des garanties financières dès
le début de leur construction afin
d'assurer le démantèlement et la remise
en état du site
après son exploitation pour les
éoliennes en mer
la législation obliger les exploitants à
constituer ces garanties dès le début de
leur construction disposition qui n'est
actuellement plus prévu par le texte que
nous examinons aujourd'hui une telle
obligation nous paraît cependant tout à
fait utile car assurant un filet de
sécurité en cas de défaillance de
l'exploitant
si d'aventuré pour une raison ou pour
une autre
l'exploitation du parc doit être
abandonné en cours de route ou quelques
années après sa mise en oeuvre
que se passera-t-il et si l'entreprise
changé de même quelle garantie
avons-nous qu'après l'exploitation les
éoliennes seront démantelés senti la
route un sou à la collectivité
force est en effet de constater que les
projets d'éoliennes en mer sont
généralement de grandes dimensions ce
qui augure d'un coup tu de démantèlement
élevé nécessitant des fonds financiers
importants
au final il s'agit de faire
oeuvres de prudence en rétablissant une
disposition qui a été supprimé
soulignons encore qui n'est pas exigé
que la totalité de ces garanties soient
constitués dès le début un décret devant
préciser les conditions de constitution
de ces dernières donc la reconstitution
de ces garanties financières pour être
progressive
l'essentiel étant qu'elles puissent
commencer à se faire dès le début de la
construction d'éoliennes
ce serait plus prudent tel est le sens
de cette amende madame la présidente
merci quel est l'avis de la commission
l'amendement défendu par monsieur
courteau qui qui est compréhensible
tendrait à aggraver l'éolien offshore
enfin en mer par rapport à l'éolien
terrestre puisque l'amendement que vous
défendez ne concerne que l'amendement en
mer que l'éolien en mer
or le texte l'article l 553 3 prévoit
bien que pour l'installation produisant
de l'électricité à partir d'énergie
mécanique
c'est en cours d'exploitation donc ce
qu'il s'agit non pas de l'éolien
terrestre mais bien de l'éolien maritime
à vrai dire l'éolien terrestre et
maritime ont la même disons construction
économique c'est à dire qu'on peut
constituer des réserves qu'à partir du
moment où on gagne de l'argent ou au
moins on a un chiffre d'affaires et je
ne je ne vois pas à l'heure même
d'ailleurs que probable en clair que
l'avenir enfin je m'avance peut-être
mais que l'avenir de l'éolien plutôt en
mer que sur terre quand on entend les
amendements de monsieur bizet défendu et
l'éolien en mer peut-être que notre
collègue nous en parlera tout à l'heure
mais
à vrai dire nous sommes défavorable à
cet amendement parce qu'il tendrait à
aggraver la charge de l'éolien en mer
alors même qu' il n'y a pas de raison
supplémentaire par rapport à l'éolien
terrestre d'aggraver cette charge donc
l'avis est défavorable
si vous leur tirez monsieur courteau
l'avis du gouvernement madame le
ministre
oui les éoliennes en mer sont
effectivement pas géré par le code de
l'environnement mr par le code de la
législation pardon relatives à
l'occupation du domaine public maritime
ceci dit le texte de l'article 40 de
l'article 34 ans voit un décret et dans
ce décret il est bien prévu qu'elles
constituent des garanties financières
dès le début pas simplement cours mais
dès le début donc votre moment sera
satisfait monsieur courteau pour
demander la parole oui quand tony madame
la présidente des précisions apportées
par madame la ministre je retire
volontiers l'amendement
merci
l'amendement 96 et retiré l'amendement
numéro 539 monsieur courteau monsieur
raoul monsieur courteau oui si vous me
permettez moi présidente je défendrai
les amendements c 130 et 140 en même
temps je tiens d'ailleurs à ce propos
signaler pour autant qu'il doit y avoir
une petite coquille dans le deuxième
mouvement du paragraphe durant sept j'ai
noté qu'il était fait référence un petit
c au lieu d'un petit peu enfin sauf
erreur sauf erreur de ma part
les éoliennes en mer sont actuellement
soumises à plusieurs procédures
d'autorisation comme pour l'éolien
terrestre
elles sont soumises à une étude d'impact
et à une étude une enquête publique à
l'autorisation d'occupation temporaire
du domaine public et aux permis de
construire
ces procédures sont utiles et n'entrave
en rien le développement de l'éolien qui
doit être encadré on peut
comme je le suis être défenseurs de
l'éolien et admettre qu'il est
nécessaire d'encadrer le développement
de ce type d'énergie surtout quand il
s'agit de notre littoral de notre espace
maritime ou des zones de pêche les
professionnels de la pêche et l'on sait
les difficultés que traverse la
profession aujourd'hui sont d'ailleurs
très inquiets face à la multiplication
des projets de parcs éoliens en mer
ils craignent que leur implantation ne
provoque une dégradation des habitats
marins
force est de reconnaître que nous ne
pouvons pour l'instant bénéficié d'un
retour d'expérience dans ce domaine
je constate or je constate que l'on est
en train de libéraliser complètement
l'éolien marin alors que l' on
verrouille le développement de l'éolien
terrestre à l'effet et sauf erreur de ma
part
l'article 33 a exclu des aides de
l'éolien offshore
tout en lui permettant de bénéficier de
l'obligation d'achat de l'électricité
l'éolien en mer ne sera donc pas soumis
à la réglementation des ide qui sont
donne désormais des zones de
développement éolien exclusivement
terrestres
rappelons que figure dans c est d eux
des critères visant à encadrer et à
éviter la détérioration des sites et
paysages
le texte de la commission prévoit par
ailleurs de dispenser du permis de
construire ainsi que du respect des
dispositions d'urbanisme
les éoliennes en mer certes il est prévu
de faire basculer les éoliennes en mer
dans le régime des icpe dont ces
dernières ne seront plus soumises qu'à
la nouvelle procédure icpe us ainsi qu'à
l'autorisation d'occupation temporaire
du domaine public
on aimerait quand même en savoir un peu
plus sur cette nouvelle procédure icpe
sur le nouveau régime auquel l'éolien en
mer sera désormais soumis et la
réglementation qui lui sera imposée car
on peut légitimement se demander si on
ne va pas trop loin dans la
libéralisation de l'éolien offshore
le développement de l'éolien ne doit pas
se faire au détriment de l'environnement
et notamment de notre littoral quelles
garanties pour la protection de l'espace
maritime et des habitats amarin quelles
conséquences pour les zones de pêche
les réponses à ces questions permettront
à tous d'y voir plus clair puisque nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une phase de
transition de régime alors alors que se
multiplient les projets d'implantation
si je vous propose suisse il s'agit du
même thème de demander au gouvernement
de présenter l'amendement numéro 922
c'est un amendement de rédactionnel pour
rectifier une erreur de référence donc
remplacé baisser par les mots behe
erreurs que vous aviez souligné
mais la vie l'avis de la commission
alors actuellement bon pour parler des
éoliennes en mer chacun sait qu'il y en
a beaucoup
d'installer même si monsieur legrand
nous le dira il y à des projets très
importants et il faut être très très
vigilant effectivement pourquoi ne pas
faire n'importe quoi mais actuellement
les éoliennes en mer sont soumises à
trois procédures d'autorisation
différentes
l'étude d'impact et dans les lieux
publics spécifiques aux éoliennes
l'autorisation d'occupation temporaire
du domaine public et le permis de
construire
s'agissant d'ailleurs d'installations
énergétiques le permis de construire
n'est pas délivrée par monsieur le maire
mais par par le préfet du département
d'ailleurs je fais une petite parenthèse
je ne sais pas si en mer on connaît très
exactement la limite des communes
je ne sais pas c'est une question a
pioché on ne serait pas quelle mère
d'ailleurs devrait délivrer le permis de
construire donc là c'est le problème
réglé c'est le préfet et dans un souci
simplification notre commission a adopté
une disposition qui dispense les
constructions aménagements et
installations et travaux implanté en mer
de l'obtention de permis de construire
et du respect des dispositions
d'urbanisme pour en parler longtemps de
l'urbanisme en mer enfin bon ainsi les
éoliennes en mer ne seront plus soumises
qu'à deux procédures de le classement
icpe que qui est dans ce texte de loi
est celle de l'autorisation d'occupation
temporaire du domaine public et pour ces
motifs la commission a émis un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur monsieur cocteau maintenu
vous vos amendements voulait maintenant
madame la ministre
merci le président effectivement les
les procédures actuelles font que ya pas
de projet en mer qui a été autorisée ou
après multiples difficultés et ça avait
été une préconisation du commun
d'ailleurs de passer du droit de
l'urbanisme
un droit plus spécifique qui est
d'ailleurs celui qu'on applique qu on
applique pour les phares donc on ne sera
pas faro balise on ne sera pas sans
réglementation puisqu'on aura bien l'en
quête publique on aura bien l'étude de
l'étude d'impact on aura bien
l'autorisation donnée par le préfet et
puis il ya une concertation avec sur
chaque façade maritime qui est menée
actuellement par les par les préfets
donc c'est une procédure plus simple et
plus cohérente effectivement avec la
réalité matérielle puisqu'on ne sait pas
définir en mer précisément les communes
les limites de chaque commune d'où un
avis défavorable
merci monsieur legrand demandé la parole
oui oui c'est simplement merci la
présidente pour entendre le gouvernement
préciser une chose c'est vrai que
l'étude d'impact se fait projet par
projet mais lorsqu'il y a comme seul le
long de la côte ouest du département de
la manche une juxtaposition de projets
moi je souhaiterais que vous puissiez
répéter ici en séance ce que vous avez
dit en commission à savoir qu'il y aura
une étude d'impact global parce que la
segmentation des études d'impact ne
prend pas en compte l'impact paysager
c'est par exemple pour laquelle je n'ai
pas déposé d'amendement mais je
souhaiterais vous entendre pour que ce
soit acté merci qui la parole est à
madame la ministre
merci présidente c'est effectivement
l'objet de la concertation actuel de
définir des zones de développement des
zones pour l'éolien en mer pour éviter
une produite prolifération de micro
projets parce qu'effectivement alors
surtout sur les écoutes qu'on connaît
bien
il ya de multiples micros projets ou
voire de très grands donc effectivement
c'est l'objet de la concertation
actuelle merci je vais donc faire voter
sur l'amendement de d'abord l'amendement
numéro 539 de monsieur courteau ceux qui
sont favorables vont la main cet
amendement ceux qui sont contre
ne pas adopter sur le 540 même même vote
et sur l'amendement du gouvernement 922
ceux qui sont favorables à son adoption
ceux qui sont contre
il est adopté merci de l'amendement 340
n'est pas défendu ils tombent et je mets
aux voix l'ensemble de l'article 34 ceux
qui sont favorables à son adoption
l'avs lama et ceux qui sont contre
abstentions l'article 34 est adoptée
après l'artiste que 34 un article
additionnel avec un amendement
monsieur du luart il n'est pas défendu
ils tombent 340 de même situation et
après l'article 34 3 amendement faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 85 rectifié terre
485 rectifié terre défendue par monsieur
de noeuds madame le ministre président
mes chers collègues
cet amendement tend à un cure-dent
gayoom la programmation pluriannuelle
des énergies renouvelables pour ce qui
est de l'éolien je n'ai pas repris les
autres énergies
j'ai cru que leur avenir et est moins
menacée alors on me répond il est
évident que vous auriez dû mettre dans
grenelle 1
j'ai donc sous-amendé mon amendement
pour modifier l'article 19 de agua qui a
été votée en mon absence
j'avais une maladie à cette époque je
n'ai pas pu le défendre
la géographie de la france est telle
qu'elles disposent d'un ou d'une énorme
potentialité ollier
deux façades maritimes des zones de
montagne
ça vaut donc le coup madame que nous
ayons une bonne discussion sergey aux
biens et sur ce que nous voulons en
faire
cet amendement s'inscrit dans le
prolongement donc en bandoulière d
article 19 du projet de loi qui a été
votée cet article dispose en effet que
afin porter à au moins 23 % en 2020 la
part des énergies renouvelables dans la
consommation d'énergie finale des
objectifs intermédiaires seront fixés en
2009 et un bilan sera réalisé sur cette
base en 2012 dans ce sens cet amendement
propose donc une planification en termes
de puissance séparés pour georg
intéressés l'éolien maritime
la production doit être planifiée dans
le temps pour que tous les acteurs
mobilisés par leurs productions puissent
sereinement optimiser le développement
de l'énergie et viennent sans à-coups
pressé ce calendrier d'installation
d'énergies renouvelables au niveau
initiative permettrait de renforcer
l'engagement national pour
l'environnement
ce calendrier s'inscrit en cohérence
avec les objectifs communautaires avec
les objectifs fixés par le grenelle de
l'environnement
ainsi qu'avec agua de juillet 2005
enfin cet article permettrait d'éviter
le fossé qui s'est créé depuis 2006 à
cette date la programmation
pluriannuelle des investissements en
électricité prévoyait l'installation de
13 mille 500 mégawatts supplémentaires
en quatre ans pour atteindre 15 mille en
2010 or en 2009
la puissance installée depuis 2006 ne
dépasse pas quoi comment disent ils et
3500 mégawatts
le gouvernement français a accepté les
procédures de calcul et même parfois été
à l'initiative de ce qui nous a amené à
accepter un objectif de 23% d'énergie
renouvelable pour 2020 cet objectif
madame de ministres sera difficile à
atteindre
si on ne fait pas ce qu'il faut pour
guérir bien j'étais rapporteur de la
résolution paquet énergie climat en
novembre 2008
hague a finalement été adopté par et 26
puis par une directive le 23 avril 2009
avec il faut que dire une pression forte
du président sarkozy qui préside l union
à ce moment là il nous faut aujourd'hui
donner des garanties à nos partenaires
qui ont accepté cette pression de la
france que nous tiendrons est apparu que
nous leur avons donné ce que je
recherche dans ce texte
sega garantie qu'à position de la france
n'a pas changé
un aspect pas souvent évoqué je voudrais
gore après vingt-cinq mille mégawatts à
raison de 1 à 1,2 million
d'investissement par machine
si l'on considère qu'il faudra faire
d'imigw machine ça paie 10 à 12
milliards d'investissements on ne me dit
pas suffisamment on parle toujours de ce
qui est négatif dans cette affaire on ne
parle pas des aspects positifs
on a fait des campagnes médiatisé pour
bien moins que ça alors bien sûr il ya
aussi dans cette affaire un aspect
d'équipements industriels
vous allez me répondre madame humilité
je m'y attends la majeure partie des
machines qui transforme l'énergie du
vent ne sont pas fabriqués en france je
voudrais à ce sujet soulevé un point qui
m'inquiète pour quelles raisons les
grands établissements industriels
français qui étaient placés pour
fabriquer des machines il ya cinq ans
dans lequel gouvernement et parfois
nettement un actionnaire de référence
ont choisi la position vous connaissez
je tiens en fonction tous ces
considérations mesdames à être rassurés
eu la meilleure assurance que vous
pourriez me donner c'est d'inscrire dans
la loi une programmation si monsieur de
monsieur courteau l'amendement 542 oui
madame la présidente de la programmation
pluriannuelle des investissements a
retenu pour l'éolien les objectifs
proposés par le commande 10 à savoir un
parc éolien installé devant
c'est 1000 mégawatts gouvernement appelé
lors du grenelle à une planification
pour garantir un développement maîtrisé
des énergies renouvelables le texte que
nous examinons aujourd'hui prévoit par
ailleurs de renforcer la planification
territoriale avec des schémas régionaux
mais le pensons que pour essentiel que
soient ses dispositions
elle ne saurait seul suffire à
déclencher une dynamique
d'investissement
ça m'a mise en place d'une réelle
planification en termes de puissance ce
que propose notre amendement
la production doit être d'autres en
effet être planifiée dans le temps pour
que les acteurs comme il a déjà été dit
qu'il s'agisse des administrations des
industriels et des élus puissent
optimiser le développement de l'énergie
éolienne sans à coups il est utile de
rappeler mais mon collègue de ne l'a
fait que la pays 2006 prévoyait
l'installation de 13 mille 500 mégawatts
supplémentaires en quatre ans pour
atteindre 15 mille mégawatts
or en 2009 la puissance installée ne
dépasse pas les 3500 mégawatts
voilà une situation que nous ne
souhaitons pas voir se reproduire la
mise en oeuvre d'une véritable
planification par période de trois ans
jusqu'en 2020 permettra
incontestablement d'éviter qu'un nouveau
le fossé ne se creuse entre objectifs et
résultats en donnant une visibilité à
long terme à tous les acteurs du secteur
au premier rang desquels les producteurs
et investisseurs j'ajouterai encore que
c'est là aussi que réside la clé de la
création et de la pérennisation
d'emplois liés à ces nouvelles énergies
sans visibilité sur le long terme les
anticipations ne peuvent être que
négative et les liquidités prêtes à
s'investir dans la production sommes
détournées vers les sphères financières
actuellement le rendement à court terme
est assuré
il faut remédier à cette situation où au
final l'investissement demeure atone
alors que les pagnes est importante tels
sont les arguments que je tenais à
exprimer à travers
la défense de cet amendement qu'il est
indispensable selon nous d'adopter qui
est monsieur muller un amendement
identique
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre collègues
le grenelle 1 avait effectivement appelé
à une planification pour développer mais
de manière maîtrisée l'éolien de notre
pays la planification territoriale est
là mais la planification en termes de
puissance manque
j'estime aujourd'hui que cette
planification en termes de puissance est
tout à fait indispensable pour que
l'engagement de développer l'éolien
puisse être tout simplement crédible en
effet les objectifs communautaires
auxquelles nous sommes maintenant partie
prenante ne fixe d'arriver à 23%
d'énergies renouvelables et aujourd'hui
nous ne pouvons pas ne pas nous passer
de l'éolien pour atteindre cet objectif
je voudrais souligner par rapport aux
défenses d'amendements qui ont été faits
par mes collègues
un point qui me paraît important c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la france accuse un
regain un retard particulièrement
important entre l'éolien déjà développé
et son potentiel
que se passe-t-il à l'étranger je
constate que les états unis mettent le
nucléaire en veille et développe un
programme éolien
la chine vient de retenir l'option
éolienne pour assurer sa consommation
électrique d'ici 2030
la grande bretagne a pris une décision
forte pour fournir toute l'énergie
électrique domestique à partir
d'éoliennes offshore
l'allemagne est déjà aujourd'hui à 25
mille mégawatts installés l'espagne à
20000 nous sommes à quatre mille alors
que nous avons le 2e site éolien en
europe
le deuxième potentiel éolien en europe
je crois qu'il faut absolument combler
ce retard s'en donner les moyens et donc
planifier le développement de l'éolien
non pas seulement de manière
territoriales mais en terme de puissance
merci l'avis de la commission
sur l'ensemble du diamant je répondrai
collectivement aux trois amendements
puisque finalement entre l'amendement de
monsieur d'honneur monsieur müller son
monsieur courteau seuls les chiffres
diffèrent encore que les deux
abonnements monsieur courteau monsieur
muller ne s'inscrivent pas dans le
grenelle a par conséquent à ceci près je
répondrai quand même d'une façon globale
pour vous dire que sur le fond
l'amendement 485 rectifié terre se
différencie des deux amendements
suivant les 542 608 par les chiffres
alors notre commission n'a pas jugé bon
de tenir de donner un avis favorable
aucun des ces trois événements parce
qu'il lui a semblé monsieur desessard
attendait parce qu'il nous a semblé que
le cadre naturel pour fixer les
objectifs de cette nature et la paix
pays programmation pluriannuelle
d'investissement pour la production
d'électricité
toutefois depuis son examen par la
commission l'amendement 485 a été
rectifié pour venir s'insérer dans la
loi de programmation relative à la mise
en oeuvre du grenelle de l'environnement
c'est un jeu un support juridique qui à
titre personnel me paraît convenir
davantage pour une programmation du
développement de l'énergie éolienne et
c'est pourquoi avant de confirmer ou non
l'avis défavorable de la commission sur
ce sujet et je demanderai deux choses la
première monsieur de ne sait que dans le
tableau que vous présentez en impression
pour l'année 2015 2017 on n'installe pas
plus de puissance éolienne en mer que
pour la période précédente
alors pourquoi et deuxièmement
j'aimerais bien entendre l'avis du
gouvernement sur le sujet merci madame
la ministre
merci madame la présidente
j'ai bien compris que ces différents
amendements c'était un appel du pied
entre guillemets pour confirmer les
engagements du gouvernement dans les
engagements du grenelle d'ailleurs pour
tenir les objectifs concernant le
développement en général d énergie et
des énergies renouvelables
jamais on est bon on est totalement
déterminé parce que ce qui est notre
maintenant bête noire entre guillemets
ce sont les énergies fossiles
c'est vraiment les énergies fossiles
qu'il faut réduire et on a un groupe
compte aussi un en france effectivement
sur la plus
or des énergies on a un potentiel en
solaire on a un potentiel en éolien on a
un potentiel en biomasse qui est
sous-exploité en un potentiel en
géothermie
donc c'est un potentiel qui est valable
pour notre balance commerciale
parce que si on tient les objectifs du
grenelle en la manière de 25% à
l'horizon 2020 et c'est un potentiel
intéressant en termes d'emploi ce qu'on
n'a pas réussi à faire dans le domaine
de l'éolien il faut qu'on réussisse en
tout cas dans le domaine du solaire vous
parler d'industrie
je pense que dans le domaine du solaire
il faut pas rater le train du le train
du solaire donc vous l'avez rappelé on
est on a passé la barre des 4000
mégawatts
oui on a du retard c'est certain mais on
a passé la barre des 4000 et depuis le
début de l'année 36 % de hausse des
raccordements autorisé et c'est vrai que
la première région en raccordement
autorisé en puissance autorisée c'est
effectivement la vôtre ce dont on a
beaucoup souffert pour le développement
de l'éolien
ce sont les réticences globalement de la
population et donc aussi le recours en
contentieux
c'était des réticences qui était aussi
liée effectivement peut-être un manque
de volonté affichée donc c'est vrai
qu'un des actes 1er de la loi s'est déjà
essayé de donner une sécurisation du
cadre juridique dans lesquelles le
développement de l'éolien se se ce cadre
alors sûr c'est sur vos propositions
effectivement c'est pas le bon lieu la
loi on avait déjà discuté d'ailleurs en
grenelle 1 pour fixer des objectifs on
préfère le mettre dans la paix pays donc
l'engagement qui est le nôtre c'est que
dans la prochaine paie pays qui n'est
pas encore sorti dans la paix pays on
met des objectifs intermédiaires et on
met notamment un objectif dès 2012 on
met un objectif intermédiaire non le
mais pas seulement sur l'éolien il
faudra qu'on met sur l'éolien mais il
faut aussi qu'on le mette sur le solaire
il faut aussi qu'on le mette sur la
biomasse et sur la géothermie enfin les
autres formes d'énergies renouvelables
parce que c'est normalement dans le
cadre de la paix pays de se déterminer
sinon à quoi ça servirait d'avoir une
paix pays
à voter des lois parfaite
monsieur muller vous avez demandé la
parole je vous propose de rectifier mon
amendement pour tenir compte des
observations faites mais pour écrire
quand même quelque chose dans la loi
nous avons bien compris que on serait
plutôt sur le grenelle 1
puisqu'on parle de planification que de
grenelle 2 alors je vous propose de
rédiger le premier alinéa de mon
amendement de la manière suivante après
le dernier alinéa du 2 de l'article 19
de la loi numéro 2009 967 de
programmation relative à la mise en
oeuvre du grenelle de l'environnement a
ajouté un alinéa ainsi rédigé
donc nous proposons la planification
mais nous l'inscrivons dans le grenelle
1 puisque c'est c'est pas trop possible
dans le grenelle 2 l'avis de la
commission s'il vous plaît après a bien
bien avoir entendu l'avis et
singulièrement de la commission et
puisque nous avons l'assurance de du
gouvernement puisque nous avons
l'assurance qu'il y aura une loi p pays
qui nous indiquera des échelons
intermédiaires entre 2020 entre
aujourd'hui et 2020
je pense que les amendements les trois
abandons et nous sont proposés
deviennent de ce fait inutile et je
propose aux uns et aux autres à monsieur
données en particulier de retirer son
amendement
monsieur denis
cette discussion est intéressante je
remercie madame le ministre des
assurances qu'elle peut donner mais je
suis toujours inquiet quand une ministre
nous sommes des assurances parce que on
a assisté depuis cinq ans dans ce pays à
la naissance de hobby entier aux biens
qui n'ont pas grand chose à voir avec
incompétence énergétique et dont état
civil parfois gaz supposées qui prépare
pas l'avenir
alors cette même un peu inquiétant de
voir comment on peut manier ces choses
bon ceci étant dit moi je retiens de ce
débat qui a un engagement du
gouvernement et je veux bien enlever cet
amendement sous promesse que nous en
reparlerons que nous vivons une période
où il ya plus de planification mais on
ne fait rien de sérieux sont qu'un
script à quelques pins bien merci
monsieur désir a demandé la parole
monsieur de ne m'avait dit monsieur
lessard est ce que serait la lundi soir
lundi après midi
je suis évidemment monsieur de ne venir
défendre votre amendement bon alors
monsieur ne faut pas le retirer il faut
le maintenir bon pourquoi monsieur le
rapporteur vous savez très bien que les
ministres passent ils passent même plus
vite que que les sénateurs bon c'est pas
imaginer que madame jouanno vue d'une
ministre excellente par ailleurs se
présente aux élections régionales est
l'élu d'un grandes régions de france
on la voit plus elle est prise lancé
dans son travail à ce moment là qu'est
ce qui va nous garantir que les
engagements qu'elle a pris aujourd'hui
seront tenus nous avons quand même
l'habitude de ces de ce gouvernement qui
nous fait des promesses ici et qui a du
mal du fait de la continuité
gouvernementale elle est maintenir donc
à les tenir donc il faudrait quand même
qu'on qu'on puisse avoir dans la loi des
objectifs chiffrés cela sera intéressant
cela va nous rassurer tous non seulement
nous mais l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
qui nous regardent
merci monsieur guillaume maintenant et
la parole mais madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
quand même remercier notre collègue
desessard du soutien public qu'ils
apportent à madame jouanno pour les
futures élections régionales mais
c'était pas totalement le sujet de de
l'après midi pour notre part nous
appellerons la personne avec les usa
l'union de chaleur pour voir cette
collusion magnifique
revenons à revenons à nos moutons madame
la ministre
ce texte là est un texte fondamental
vendredi chaque fois et lorsque nous
avons des actes un peu fort qui veulent
graver dans le marbre de la loi des
choses on a évoqué la semaine dernière
le schéma votre photovoltaïque
on nous a renvoyés à autre chose là on
évoque la puissance de l'éolien on nous
dit ça sera dans la paix pays
nous il nous semble malgré tout et tout
à l'heure c'était le cas aussi sur
d'autres amendements il nous sommes
malgré tout que ce texte grenelle 2 de
l'environnement doit marquer l'histoire
et si l intérieur de ce texte il n'est
jamais d'angle
on efface tout au profit de plus tard au
profil une commission au profit d'une
étude au profit d'une paix pays au
profit d'autres choses
il nous semble que ce texte manquera de
force
il s'impose à tous c'est un texte
fondamental que veut enfin le
gouvernement c'est la raison pour
laquelle même si je comprends bien
l'argument de madame la ministre
il se pourrait appartenant à partir par
exemple de la demande l'an rectifié de
jacques muller que ça puisse être
accepté à la fois par la commission et
par l'est et par la ministre tout en
entendant très bien que dans la paix
pays des choses seront indiqués mais
vraiment vraiment vraiment il manque
dans ce texte dans ce grenelle ii des
angles il manque des arêtes qui nous
permettent de fixer bien les choses
merci monsieur monsieur courteau est ce
que vous maintenez votre amendement où
nous allons nous rallier madame la
présidente
la proposition est donc à l'amendement
rectifié de monsieur muller alors s'il
n'y a pas d'autres explications de vote
se mettre aux voix à monsieur muller
rapidement très rapidement
j'entends parfaitement ce que disait
notre collègue monsieur de ne nous
sommes soumis à un lobby anti éoliens
que j'appellerais neely ni nucléaire ni
éolien dit rien du tout je peux en dire
ici maintenant la miss ne me contredira
pas un projet exemplaire
je pèse mes mots exemplaire d'un point
de vue environnemental a été bloqué sur
la crête vosgienne sur une sous crêtes
vosgiennes donc entre l'alsace et les
vosges sous la pression de lobbyistes
intégré il faut les appeler comme ça et
c'est la raison pour laquelle un
engagement en faveur de l'éolien doit
reposer sur un texte et je propose donc
pour tenir compte de ce qui a été dit de
mettre cette planification dans le
grenelle 1 plutôt que dans le grenelle 2
met au piano que je vais donc faire
voter sur l'amendement 608 rectifiée
présentée par monsieur muller ceux qui
sont favorables à son adoption voudront
bien levé la main
ceux qui sont contre
il n'est pas adopté alors pour vous
rassurer monsieur désessard nous allons
faire un vote debout assis ceux qui sont
favorables à l'amendement non favorable
à l'amendement se lèveront alors
ceux qui sont opposés à l'amendement
présenté par 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 et adopte
l'amendement est adopté
alors après à l'article 35 1 3
amendement faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune
l'amendement numéro 543 monsieur
courteau oui maintenant le président cet
article près par la cik 35 le
renouvellement des concessions
hydroélectriques en aménageant les
redevances sur les ventes d'électricité
que percevait jusqu'à maintenant l'état
et les départements concernés force est
de rappeler que l'hydraulique contribue
pour environ 10 % la production
nationale totale d'électricité en 2007
elles représentent 88 % de la production
totale d'électricité d'origine
renouvelable
à cela s'ajoute le fait que
l'hydroélectricité est très précieuse
pour assurer la régulation du système
électrique notamment parce que parce
cette énergie stockée permet de faire
face aux pics de consommation et de
fournir en quelques minutes dans la
puissance au réseau elle est également
précieuse du fait qu'elle aimait pas de
gaz à effet de serre et permet ainsi de
contribuer aux objectifs de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
pour faire face au changement climatique
or suite à l'ouverture du marché de
l'électricité à la concurrence au
changement du statut d'edf en société
anonyme et suite à la suppression du
droit de préférence dont jouissait edf
le renouvellement des concessions
hydroélectriques est désormais soumis à
concurrence par le biais de la procédure
d'appel d'offres
le décret 2008
1009 signé en juillet 2008 a procédé à
la refonte du régime des concessions
hydroélectriques et à concrétiser la
mise en concurrence des concessions des
barrages or ce ne sont pas moins de
quelques 400 concessions d'une puissance
de 90 200 mégawatts qui sont concernés
80% de ces concessions sont exploités
par edf
l'enjeu du renouvellement est donc de
taille les opérateurs concurrents d'edf
susceptibles de répondre à l'appel
d'offres sont nombreux gaz de france
suez qui exploite déjà 47 ouvrage mais
également l'allemand et l'espagnol
iberdrola ou encore le suisse alpiq et
c'est le comprend aisément que les
ouvrages d'hydroélectricité qui
permettent aux opérateurs de répondre à
leurs engagements européens en
augmentant leur capacité de production
d'énergie renouvelable sont très
convoités ils sont d'autant plus
convoités créé ouvrages sont amorties
depuis longtemps et qu avec la
libéralisation des marchés énergétiques
les prix de l'électricité ont fortement
augmenté
la rente et hydroélectrique est donc
très alléchante pour tout nouveau
concessionnaire est l'un des enjeux
essentiels porte sur la répartition de
cette entente comme le souligner un
rapport du conseil des mines de fin 2006
consacré à cette question
bah écoutez madame la présidente je ne
passe pas avoir écoulé mon temps de
parole sur laquelle je m'appuie y
écouter vraiment alors je suis quand
même assez surpris bob écouter
considérer considérer que l'amendement
est défendu merci merci de votre
compréhension et de me faire confiance
quand je vous dis que j'ai une pendule
sous les yeux monsieur l'amendement du
mien aussi 109 monsieur muller monsieur
desessard
monsieur muller très bien monsieur
monsieur muller vous avez la parole pour
l'amendement 609 on dit madame la
présidente madame la ministre cet
amendement s'inscrit donc dans le
développement de la production
électrique
la production électrique grâce à l'eau
et nous estimons que c'est effectivement
un dispositif qui méritent d'être
développées pour autant il faut que les
les règles en vigueur soit parfaitement
respecté et on se rend compte que trop
souvent les concessionnaires ne
respectent pas les prescriptions
relatives à la continuité écologique
c'est-à-dire un débit biologique minimum
pour permettre la circulation des
poissons
donc nous proposons ici de prévoir une
sanction financière
lorsque les règles ne sont pas
respectées tout simplement merci
monsieur courteau vous voulez vous
présenté l'amendement 544 rectifier
c'est moi madame la présidente
cet amendement s'inscrit dans la
continuité donc de l'amendement
précédent que tenter de défendre mon
collègue courteau nous souhaitons
instaurer un plancher pour la redevance
dans la mesure où l'amortissement de la
plupart des ouvrages d'un côté et
l'augmentation des prix d'électricité
sur le marché de l'autre suffisent à
justin le justifier dans ce rapport le
conseil des min préconisait également
l'instauration d'une telle redevance
minimale en compensation notamment de la
suppression de l'énergie réservé qui
permettait de faire bénéficier aux
services publics de l'état au
département aux communes et c'est une
énergie bon marché
notre amendement ne vise que les gros
exploitants raison pour laquelle nous
prévoyons qu'un décret fixe un seuil en
deçà duquel les concessions
d'hydroélectricité ne seraient pas
concernés ici merci
l'avis de la commission s'il vous plaît
monsieur le rapporteur alors sur cet
important problème de les concessions et
la redistribution de cette cette
redevance
c'est une question importante des gars
vous avez noté que par rapport au texte
initial du gouvernement la commission
l'a modifié alors trois amendements
intéressants les uns les autres nous
sont proposés le premier celui défendu
par monsieur courteau et soutenu tente
la redevance sur les concessions
hydrauliques tic est actuellement
plafonné de manière générale à 25% vous
le savez des recettes
ce taux apparaît aujourd'hui trop bas
alors que les concessions qui arrive
renouvellement sont depuis longtemps
amortis
il est toutefois important nous semble
utile de maintenir le principe d'un
plafond qui seraient fixés lors de la
procédure de mise en concurrence des
concessions de manière à ce que cette
concurrence ne s'exerce pas uniquement
sur le taux de la redevance mais aussi
sur les aspects relatifs à l'entretien à
la sécurité à l'environnement puisque
monsieur muller d'ailleurs ce est très
soucieux à juste titre d'ailleurs ce
sera l'environnement et donc ça ne peut
pas être qu'une une course finalement et
au taux le plus élevé pour obtenir cette
concession la mesure où tant qu'on
arrive pas à 100% c'est toujours un plus
juteux dans la mesure où ces
installations sont pour la plupart
amorti en bon état donc ce plafond ne
sera pas général mais fixer au cas par
cas précise ans pour tenir compte de
l'installation en cause en fonction des
paramètres économiques de chacune des
concessions hydroélectriques concernées
et donc nous sommes contre la commission
contre le déplafonnement complet du taux
de la redevance pour ces concessions
électrique
concernant l'amendement de monsieur
muller qui me rassure faudrait déjà que
le taux ne dépasse pas 50% pour le
doublé mais ceci étant dit le doublement
de la redevance serait une sanction
financière qui nous semblent
disproportionnées et qui pourrait
compromettre
d'autant plus qu'elle se rapproche des
cadets 50 % effectivement si le taux est
très bas ce serait pas très élevé et qui
pourrait compromettre l'équilibré
économique de la concession et pour
autant la méconnaissance des articles
l214 17 et 214 18 du code de
l'environnement n'est pas dépourvue de
sanctions tant pénale qu'administrative
d'ailleurs le gouvernement nous le dira
sans doute et l'autorité administrative
peut faire procéder en lieu et place de
l'expo temps et à ses frais aux travaux
nécessaires et pour ces raisons l'avis
de la commission est défavorable enfin
pour le troisième en amendement le 544
rectifié de monsieur courteau c'est
qu'ils tentent à instaurer un taux
minimal sais pas c'est même plus à des
plafonnements 7,1 à taux minimum un
plancher qu un taux plancher de 15 %
pour les redevances des plus grosses
installations hydroélectriques et je
rappellerai que dans la mesure où
plafond de 25% des recettes est jugé
trop bas il n'y a guère de raison pour
que l'autorité concédante fixe le
plafond au dessous de 15%
l'objectif est bien de retirer davantage
de recettes des concessions
hydroélectriques à l'occasion de leur
gouvernement d'ailleurs vous avez noté
que dans le texte de loi les communes
toucheront avec les départements et
toutes les communes les communes parce
qu'il peut y avoir plusieurs les
départements d'ailleurs pu y en avoir
plusieurs aussi toucheront alors que ce
n'est pas le cas sous la législation
1919 et par conséquent l'avis est
défavorable sur cet amendement 544 de
match au couteau
merci madame la ministre l'avis du
gouvernement merci madame la présidente
bien tout à tout a été dit sur
l'amendement 543 la suppression d'un
plafond fait qu'effectivement se référer
uniquement au critère économique sans
prendre en compte les critères
énergétiques et environnementaux d'où un
avis défavorable sur la maman s'y sont
neufs
c'est pas la vocation de la redevance
l'hydroélectricité d'être une sanction
les sanctions dans le cadre de la loi
sur l'eau s'applique donc on doit un
avis défavorable
enfin idem s'agissant d'un taux plancher
puisque celui-ci al'inverse ne
permettrait pas de valoriser des petits
de plus petits projets et pourrait même
obérer les investissements souhaitable
dans le cadre environnemental
si si explications de vote monsieur
muller madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur au regard des explications
que vous m'avez donné je vais bien
retirer mon amendement 609,9 retrait
merci monsieur courteau vous maintenez
votre amendement
oui je vais donc faire voter sur
l'amendement présenté par monsieur
courteau et autres socialistes ceux qui
sont favorables à son adoption
ceux qui sont contre
il n'est pas adopté l'amendement numéro
544 rectifier mais si raul a demandé la
parole oui on en discute avec mes
collègues et en écoutant attentivement
madame la ministre concernant je dirais
le big business plan de petites
installations qui pourrait être remis en
cause par ce plancher
je crois que effectivement on pourrait
le retirer à gagner du temps et
amendement est retiré et je fait voter
sur l'article 35
ceux qui sont d'avis de l'adopter sertic
35 seront bien levé la main l'article 35
bien sûr bien ceux qui sont contre
abstentions l'article 35 est adoptée
après l'article 25 un article
additionnel avec deux amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
monsieur de ne présente l'amendement
numéro 164 rectifié père madame la
ministre madame la présidente
c'est un amendement qu'il dit toute
personne physique ou morale exerçant une
activité agricole au sens de l'article l
311 1 du code rural peut exploiter ou
faire exploiter des panneaux
photovoltaïques ainsi que toute
installation de production d'électricité
ou de chaleur à partir de produits ou de
sous produits majoritairement issus de
son exploitation que je vous explique le
texte
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir fournir de
l'énergie lorsque les espaces agricoles
n'est obligé de passer par le statut de
sociétés commerciales
or 70 % des boîtes agricole qui compte
dans ce pays sont aujourd'hui en société
civile c'est à dire grec ou earl n'ont
donc pas le droit de produire de
l'énergie au sens juridique du terme
c'est seul objet alors afin de lever cet
obstacle
il est proposé d'autoriser les
agriculteurs ou et société civile
agricole à exploiter ou faire exploiter
des panneaux photovoltaïques ou toute
installation de production d'électricité
ou de chaleur à partir de biomasse
majoritairement issus des exploitations
c'est bien de l'exploitation agricole
qu'il s'agit
merci l'amendement est tombé car le
mandement numéro 5 186 rectifié beast et
n'est pas défendu l'avis de la
commission sur l'amendement présenté par
monsieur de noeuds c'est un sujet
monsieur deneux qu'on connaît bien
puisque cela concerne toutes les
activités qui ne sont pas agricole est
exercée au sein d'une activité agricole
et vous le savez très bien monsieur 2
cela rapporte au régime fiscal de
l'activité qui est exercée donc là vous
auriez mieux fait de dire dans votre
abonnement
l'activité de production d'électricité
renouvelable à partir du photovoltaïque
est assimilée dans des limites et c'est
au compte d'exploitation de
l'exploitation agricole et par
conséquent elle est redevable de la tva
et l'exonération de tva xterra et donc
vous auriez apportez vous même la
réponse cela relève d'une loi de
finances et non pas du grenelle 2 est
donc je suis désolé je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous je l'avais dit
d'ailleurs madame ferrade le retirer
pour leur présenter à l'occasion d'une
vote finances ou loi de finances
rectificative en l'occurrence on fait ça
les 22 et 23 décembre vous voyez une
heure du matin on glisse cette affaire
là et là je serais tout à fait vrai je
serai pas le rapporteur et je serai dans
l'hémicycle et je voterai pour mais là
ça ne rentre pas du tout dans le cadre
du grenelle 1 voilà vous le savez bien
mais aussi le 2 mai madame le ministre
l'avis de du gouvernement et je vous
donnerai la parole après monsieur donner
la priorité aux deux présidentes bien
sûr les
on partage tout à fait l'objectif
supprimer les tracasseries pour les
agriculteurs parce que c'est vrai que
c'est extrêmement complexe donc on a un
début de réponse d'ailleurs apporté à
l'article 33
concernant le solaire mais là on voit
même sur cet amendement en fait une
société agricole pourrait civil agricole
pardon pourrait être requalifiée en
sociétés commerciales s'il réalise des
actes de commerce avec des conséquences
fiscales donc ce que je vous propose
c'est que en tout cas pour tout ce qui
est partie tracasseries entre guillemets
qu'on retravaille avec eric woerth et
bruno le maire pour avoir quelque chose
notamment dans le cadre de la partie
assemblée nationale pour la l'autre
lecture à l'assemblée nationale et que
par contre pour les aspects fiscaux sur
lesquels là je serai plus réservé ce
soit éventuellement viewer vu
effectivement loi de finances monsieur
vous avez ne vais pas demander la parole
monsieur d'aisé ça alors je donne la
parole à monsieur deneux qui me l'a
demandé
moi je remercie gros porteurs et madame
le ministre demeure des questions je
compte sur vous pour prévenir monsieur
jour ce que dans la nuit du 11 au 12
décembre
il faudra accepter un amendement que
nous proposerons parce qu'ils vivent est
vrai que il y a des incidences fiscales
que lui amendement présenté n'est
peut-être pas le meilleur dans son lit
bébé mais je retiens que gouvernement
est favorable est le rapporteur
des essarts qui se posent légitimement
des questions dans le cadre de la loi
actuelle et des lois actuelles rien
n'empêche des agriculteurs même en
société sils de le faire mais ils le
font à titre privé il loue le toit de
l'ex de leurs exploitations agricoles et
peuvent le faire mais le faire dans le
cadre dans le cadre d'une exploitation
agricole cela des conséquences fiscales
en particulier très concrète très réel
et donc cela passe par une loi de
finances et non comme c'est tout c'était
pour répondre à monsieur dsa bien non
indépendamment des explications qui ont
été fournis je comprends très bien
l'intérêt de la bande mans mais je
voudrais simplement rappeler qu on a
quand même dans cette assemblée
une jurisprudence delà de l'application
de l'article 40 à géométrie variable
parce que voilà un amendement
indépendamment du fonds l'aspect fiscal
des choses relève de l'article 40 et
donc je comprend pas nos amendements
sont traités d avec un filtre à mailles
très serrées
concernant l'article 40 quand il s'agit
d'autres amendements
apparemment il ya des ouvertures
l'amendement a retiré monsieur
l'amendement a été retiré
donc il n'ya pas d'explications de vote
désolé l'amendement est retirée à
l'article après l'article 35
l'article additionnel de article 10 chez
elle à pratiquer en cinq parts dont
l'amendement numéro 3 188 que défend à
l'âme didier merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
les objectifs de développement des
énergies renouvelables à l'horizon 2020
sont très ambitieux il implique donc de
créer la dynamique nécessaire pour les
atteindre
les différents textes de mise en oeuvre
du grenelle de l'environnement propose
un ensemble d'outils techniques et
financiers importants mais dont on
évalue difficilement la dynamique réelle
qu'ils vont pouvoir créer
il nous apparaît dès lors indispensable
de mettre en place dès à présent une
évaluation périodique des mesures
de soutien et de leur impact afin de
pouvoir réajuster si nécessaire le
niveau de soutien technique et financier
au regard de l'ampleur des
transformations exigé il nous semble
donc utile d'en surveiller attentivement
l'évolution
c'est pourquoi nous préconisons
l'introduction d'un rapport annuel
d'évaluation de l'ensemble des mesures
de soutien au développement des énergies
renouvelables qui étudierait en
particulier la compatibilité des
développements constatée pour les
différentes filières avec les objectifs
de développement fixés pour 2012 et 2020
voilà pourquoi nous vous suggérons
d'adopter cet amendement si madame
didier l'avis de la commission
je dirais à l'auteur de cet amendement
tout au moins ceux et celles qui le
soutient qu'une approche évaluative est
toujours la bienvenue
c'est évident mais elle peut s'inscrire
d'ailleurs cette approche évaluative
dans le cadre ordinaire des relations
non moins ordinaire d'information et de
contrôle entre le gouvernement et le
parlement
par exemple lors de discussions
budgétaires à l'occasion de questions
cribles thématiques crible et c'est sans
qu'il soit besoin de demander un rapport
de plus j'ajouterai puisque ont fait de
l'écologie vous souvenez que dans le
grenelle 1 on a voté l'économie de
papier puisqu'on a demandé à ce que les
administrations ne dit pas non pas de
50% mais moitié ce qui est différent
quand même la consommation de papier ci
est ce que vous vous êtes amusé à peser
le poids du courrier qui arrive à chaque
sénateur toutes les semaines
c'est effrayant et je pense qu'il ferait
bon qu'on est moindre apport ou qu'ils
soient moins volumineux qu'il soit mis
en ligne sur internet qu'on les consulte
qu'on soit visible
par une feuille simple qu'on peut les
consulter mais qu'on nous envoie pas le
rapport complet je pense que là c'était
l'occasion pour moi de le dire a
toujours pour toutes ces raisons madame
didier l'avis est défavorable
la ville du gouvernement madame la
ministre
en fait oui merci madame la présidente
votre amendement il satisfait puisque
dans le cadre de la loi dite grenelle 1
s'est engagé à faire un bilan
intermédiaire en 2012 et on le fera
d'ailleurs en fonction des objectifs
fixés intermédiaire fixé dans la paix
pays
madame didier oui madame la présidente
j'ai bien entendu comme disent les
rapporteurs je lui sais gré de de cette
réponse j'aurais aimé une réponse
davantage sur le fond je conviens bien
qu'un rapport de plus c'est beaucoup de
kilos de papier on est bien d'accord
pour autant un tableau de bord mis en
place et rendue publique pourrait aurait
pu être une bonne réponse à savoir le
ministère rend public ce tableau de bord
je pense que c'est faisable facilement
et ça nous permettrait peut-être
j'aurais aimé plus tôt une réponse de ce
type je retire mon amendement vous
retirez très bien je vous en remercier
vous venez de suivre l'examen du projet
de loi dit grenelle 2 pour revoir cette
séance notre site internet
publicsenat.fr tout de suite le journal
de 18 heures présenté par michel
grossiord merci de votre fidélité et à
très bientôt sur public sénat